don't stick your fingers in animals but
speak if you want to lose a hand run up
and stick your finger into Tigers but
this is not a good thing to do I'm
wildlife biologist Forrest Galante and
this is the breakdown up first the birds
I want you to go as quietly as possible
do not make a sound until I tell you to
run alright let's hold it there so the
grouping of Ravens or crows is called a
murder typically you'll see two or three
or four you know up to ten or twelve but
they're spread out they're an eye shot
of each other but they're still one in
this tree one in that tree in this image
what I'm seeing is all of these birds
right on top of each other
shoulder-to-shoulder on top of the
jungle gym so it's very weird it's not
typical animal behavior it all those
leaves you to believe that this is
planned right that's not old coincidence
that they're all sitting there but
rather they have come together to do
this intentionally Ravens and crows are
incredibly social they're very very
intelligent birds they're able to
communicate with each other they form
family groups they actually can hold it
like a mourning ceremony when one of
them dies where the others will gather
around and they'll all start squawking
somewhat in unison to signify the
passing of one of the crows definitely
some of the smartest birds on the planet
they're also some of the most trainable
which I presume is why they were so
perfect for this film they all take off
at once and you see these kids just
screaming through the streets I think
what's so funny about this Alfred
Hitchcock film is we're taking an animal
that's very common that we see all over
the place and making it a stereo
aggressive thing they're not aggressive
animals I mean nobody that's watching
this has ever been attacked by a crow
because that's never happened they don't
just pull them out of the sky and start
attacking you it's really interesting
because some of this is clearly kind of
bad CG which is probably good CG in its
era but some of it is also real trained
animals and you can see these Ravens
flying down swooping by these kids heads
and it's pretty cool hold there for a
second
Yeah right there that's pretty funny if
a crow were to attack you given that
it's a bird this big with very limited
ability to hurt you I think nibbling on
your ear is probably about the most
damaging could
you when a crow is hunting it's really
foraging they're not an active
aggressive predator like a raptor they
don't hover over and dive on something
instead they kind of fly down peck
around through the dirt pull a worm out
of the dirt kick over a little logs it's
very sort of intelligent foraging not so
much like predatory aggression let me
jump ahead the sound in this film right
crows and ravens make a variety of
sounds in fact they're one of the most
vocal birds that we have in North
America as far as their diversity of
sounds that they can make so they can be
taught to mimic cars like a parrot or
make other sounds like other birds and
trick them but in this case the sounds
that we're hearing is like some kind of
small mammal shrews you know which I
don't know what that sounds supposed to
be a murder of crows all squawking at
the same time is it intimidating enough
thing I mean it really is an impressive
sound - here let me play that and I
think they could have just used that but
you know they decided to use this kind
of shrill squawking sound that Ravens do
not make the kind of aggression that you
see from birds today are from
cassowaries or from ostriches something
like that generally not flighted Birds
and in that situation they're just being
territorial so you just want to back off
and get away from them when it's a
flighted bird it's really challenging
because they can fly right so they have
all the maneuverability I can imagine
back when haast Eagles used to hunt
Maori children it was a terrifying thing
to have this eagle with a 15-foot
wingspan swoop down and try and take
your child away from you those animals
no longer exist but at the end of the
day when it comes to birds attacking
people it's kind of like a size thing
there's nothing that a two-pound crow
can do now if that Raven happened to be
75 pounds and have a 15-foot wingspan
you'd be in a lot of trouble this is
gold Kenny here you have both they're
asking do you have balls like are you
brave enough to go deal with the tiger
what they should be saying is do you
have brains and if he says yes he
shouldn't be going in with a tiger no I
don't know this movie I haven't seen it
I don't know the exact situation as to
how captive this tiger is obviously we
know from circus shows and
shows that certain Tigers can be very
very domesticated that being said should
anyone just go walking into a tiger
enclosure I think not these are animals
that are naturally dangerous to people
right these are the largest cats in the
world they're extremely predatory should
we just approach one on foot absolutely
not it doesn't matter if it's in the
wild or in captivity if you don't know
that animal you should not be walking up
to it holder this frame is a perfect
example of how great their camouflage is
you're seeing this little bit of orange
but that orange is blending in perfectly
with the light reflecting off of the
leaves and the green foliage and the
black stripes looks like the shadows in
between them so you picture this kind of
gold and orange creature with black
stripes you like that stands out
anywhere that's a ridiculous color
scheme but the truth is that's fantastic
camouflage perfectly mimics both
grasslands and jungle and the stripes
mimic the shadows that you get if
something moves through that
[Music]
wouldn't happen like that right maybe
with a trained tiger and enclosure sure
but in the wild the animal wouldn't
expose itself by being out in the
clearing right in fact quite the
opposite as someone approach like that
it would circle around and be in the
densest thickest foliage to stalk the
person and pounce from behind if you're
a predator you're typically pretty smart
and you know that if you attack
something head-on you're likely to get
injured but if you attack from behind
there's no way that that creature can
injure you back but you know now it's
great you can see it obviously because
it's in a clearing and there's a
standoff so let's see what happens this
is what you'd see in a standoff right
the animal would lower its ears like
that it would show its teeth this is an
aggressive body posture and that's what
it's doing it's standing off it saying
I'm aggressive don't come near me
beautiful animal hold right there I
don't recommend anybody try this but if
you're ever approaching something like a
canine or a large cat you do not want to
power over them right so Matthew
McConaughey sticking his hand out and
being over it it's expressing another
aggressive trait instead what you should
do is present your hand nice and low and
let them come to you smell you get
comfortable and then you could slowly
work to touching them and things like
that
again I don't recommend anybody do this
but if you're in that situation
don't go jamming your hand out over the
top of them that's scary you know if
you're the animal you're going oh what's
that on top of me and you could get a
fright and SWAT out it or by that it and
then you lose a hand freak this frame
down at no point in time do we see
Matthew McConaughey and the tiger this
is clearly someone else right this is
its keeper a stunt double petting him on
the head we don't see Matthew
McConaughey's face and they pop out and
you see his face again and they pop back
into a hand on the tiger they are using
the trainer or someone else because you
know it wasn't his contract too
dangerous or whatever but although this
is a captive trained animal Matthew
McConaughey did not actually pet this
tiger it's a real bummer for him because
it's nice to pet a tiger
next up welcome to the jungle Oh JC BD
great don't know the movie but anybody
that peacocks like that I'm already into
it is no tiger
what are the chances of a dangerous
animal in this island zero okay so just
where do we begin
Wow what a mess first of all we got
super Jack John Claude Van Dam hanging
out on the cliffs of what appears to be
Hawaii with a tiger just attacking out
of lava rock and how nobody saw this
tiger coming when there's not even a
bush anywhere to be seen I don't know
but I'd love it Tiger just takes him to
the ground and then doesn't bite him in
the neck it doesn't do anything and then
backs off and chills it out while he
gets up and he's like Oh careful this
right here the buzzer running or
fighting or screaming or doing anything
it just turns back to the group easily
and starts talking about the animal
that's just attacked I'm a foot away
it's great there are no Tigers in Hawaii
Tigers are from Asia right Southeast
Asia all the way up into China I mean
are there places in the world where a
tiger could be on the ocean on a rocky
cliff sure are you going to see them
standing like that absolutely not
they're back in the jungle where there's
prey sources and everything else get
afraid
your brother is that really what he said
are you positive about that no don't
stick your fingers and animals butts
people yes this is a comedy if you want
something funny to happen make jokes
about sticking your fingers in Tigers
but if you want to lose a hand run up
and stick your finger into Tigers but
this is not a good thing to do what can
you do is to defend yourself against the
Tigers not much it's a tiger it's going
to win you could go for the eyes you can
go for the ears if you really really
desperate but sticking something in this
but is not gonna do anything I have to
see this movie I don't know what this is
but I have to see this now like what a
bunch of nonsense John wick chapter
three Parabellum the so far so good all
very realistic right we're just gonna
run through stables horses aren't very
alarmed they wouldn't be there used to
people
let's go back so now John wicks doing
with you on with does is kicking some
butt we're hearing a gunshot and a
sudden you starting to hear the horses
whinny in the background that would
happen you fire a gun the horses are
gonna get agitated in western movies we
see horses riding and gunshots going off
all the time even on ranches in today's
day and age people shoot off a horseback
constantly they can definitely get
acclimated to those loud bangs and not
even notice them that's why horses were
such important vessels during war times
but in this situation I think it's safe
to assume that they're not used to
gunfire so when a loud noise like
gunfire does happen the animals are
getting upset just a quick comment John
wick they're just gently spins the horse
around and the guy who runs into it
bounces off of it like it's a vertical
trampoline like I'm not quite
understanding why horse but is the
consistency of a bounce house but for
whatever reason it managed to knock the
guy out it's a little silly but kind of
fun to watch
yeah that would do it that'll do for
anybody that knows horses you know you
never want to go around the back end of
a horse right because they kick and they
kick when they're agitated that will and
has absolutely happened people get very
badly hurt by horses kicking backwards
out of agitation just like that
it's just great I mean he's got this
like kick cannon right it you like pet
sit on the flank and it just fires out a
kick and pets it again fires out a kick
it's great TV it's not how horses work
you couldn't really command a horse when
to kick right like even if you dug your
stirrups in or if you startled it it
wouldn't necessarily kick it's more like
if you're in a headlock and you go like
that to get someone off you kind of
reaction right it's something coming up
behind you and the horse is reacting to
it some of the horses are agitated like
the horse directly behind John wick and
the guy is fighting and some of the
horses are completely calm like when he
runs and slides underneath him I'm sure
the trainers intentionally tried to make
sure that horse was very calm because if
it was a lad jeté and someone went
sliding underneath it it probably
freaked out and kick him pretty
realistic except if all this commotion
was going on I think all the horses
would be agitated
horses are working animals for the most
part right they know that when you're on
top of them they're being ridden if
you're a rider you know there's various
commands with the reins and with the
stirrups to see someone grab the horn
and fling themselves up onto the saddle
and then the horse take off that's not
odd that's how horses are they know it's
time to go and they're being ridden
you're great I don't remember the name
of the term right my sister is a big
writer I'm not but where you kind of
hang off the side of the saddle and you
can kind of wrap around you can move
forward or backwards in Gymkhana where
you compete to do these things there's
all kinds of motions like that
the idea that you hang off the horse's
neck sideways reach around shoot a guy
it's great could you do it absolutely is
it easy no but the horse would allow it
up next black sheep touch it what you
touch it I will if you will all right
what happens a lot of times as bats are
preying on small insects small insects
are attracted to lights at night so the
bats come swooping down picking off the
bugs that are circling around the porch
light or whatever it is sure enough you
know a bug darts in towards a window and
in goes the bat now all of a sudden the
bats in the house if you see a bat
curled up in your house and this is
probably something that's gonna happen
to almost everybody at one point in
their life open the window and let it
out don't go pokin it it doesn't do it
any good it doesn't do you any good
whoa I think it's gone
I hate those damn things well you just
saw was actually pretty good behavior
right so the bat flies around and then
it disappears the guys are in the corner
go no I hate bats whatever and then all
of a sudden it reappears that's exactly
what would happen right the bats stuck
in the house flies around flies around
flies around lands uses a psycho
location it's like all right I'm gonna
try and get out of here again takes off
and starts flying around again of course
it's not trying to attack anything it's
just trying to escape but they will
roost take a break and then take off
again yes they can be carriers this is
kind of idea that people contract rabies
from bats all the time is very very
far-fetched there's only a very my new
hand full of species of bats that even
bite people and those are vampire bats
so the odds of contracting rabies from
that are super slim right these animals
aren't biting people so even if the bat
has rabies odds aren't just going to die
it's they're going to bite someone and
contaminate them okay over the fridge
you hit the Lights
bats are attracted to light by in the
fridge I closed the door and a story
that's moths you dumbass not bad oh yeah
David Spade is right that is moths but
Chris Farley's actually also right
because like I said earlier the moths
are attracted to the light and then the
bats were attracted to the moth so
they're both kind of riding their wave
but saying it's moths dumbass is pretty
accurate
[Music]
watch this the thought of being able to
catch a bat by like gently clamoring two
pots together and perfectly trapping it
inside it unless the bat is landed it's
impossible you're not gonna pick it out
of the air right again it uses
echolocation so it can sense those
things coming it consents it closing it
also doesn't want to have anything to do
with you it can tell that your there is
a large mammal and it's trying
desperately to get away from you you're
not catching it in a couple pots it's
pretty funny right he thinks he's caught
the bat in the pots and then they look
in the pot they turn around and the bats
tangled and Chris Farley's hair now I've
heard stories of bats getting tangled in
woman's hair again I think this is from
a bat place swooping in to get an insect
that's landed on the back of someone's
head but it absolutely could happen now
the truth is this would be by far the
easiest point to catch the bat you've
got to just calmly walk outside and
untangle it but instead there's just
real panic now right the bats stuck in
his hair don't know what to do
apparently it's gross for some reason
and this is going to lead to I'm sure a
whole bunch more shenanigans like how
the bats just flying back and forth it's
not circling any longer it's not going
out the door it's just staying perfectly
silhouetted in there like four foot by
four foot bedsheet so their final
approach is they get a bedsheet or a
curtain whatever it is and put it up
between two broom handles right and they
they shoe the bat out the door all they
actually had to do was open the door and
the bat would have found its own way out
we've got mr. Popper's Penguins so these
are Gentoo penguins there are smaller
species they get up to maybe like
pound and you congregate like this in
flocks we all know if we've ever watched
one of these beautiful David
Attenborough planet Earth things the
Penguins like to slide on their bellies
as a means to get to the ocean going
down an iceberg and what they're
implying here with our CG Gentoo
penguins is that they've knocked over
this water and now they're using it as a
slide so they're fake penguins that are
modeled after real penguins that are
expressing a real characteristic so it's
pretty cool
penguins congregate in masses typically
for breeding they live in very large
colonies and their safety in numbers
because penguins don't make nests high
up in the trees like other birds they're
doing it on the rocky shoreline when
there's a gazillion of them all together
it's confusing for predators there's
safety in numbers it's not that that
many penguins are a deterrent for a
predator quite the opposite that many
are predator attractants but if you're
congregated in a group of several
thousands or millions the odds of you
getting picked off are one and say a
hundred thousand verses when you're one
alone out in the middle of nowhere and
you're taking on a polar bear one on one
you're going to lose the way that the
Penguins are structured with their arms
out is actually very similar to how they
swim so if you watch hang ones that have
been filmed swimming underwater they're
kind of like these glider Jets that
you're seeing here this is a very rigid
aqua dynamic body posture that you're
seeing
whereas when they're sliding it's kind
of more of a sleek like get me to the
water type of body position the behavior
is good behavior and pretty well
represented in the way that it's done
just not in a fancy dress ball obviously
what makes the movie funny that they're
doing it in the wrong situation I'm
Horace Blanton and this has been my
great
you